foreign
following the threats of her mind
she's here to find them
too high
she needs her help with a promise
when it's never so simple is it
wisdom has a prize
there's always a part of you that
changes
and part of you that darkens
and a part of you that dies over there
at the pool
I can feel them feel them everywhere The
Lost Ones they are watching us
what is going to happen it's time to
find out how can we make
you lunch it's time to find out what are
they waiting
are you waiting for I'm here
[Music]
awesome
watching more than one
I love you
are they where are you what do they want
Mike I'm scared
woman
their eyes
feel them born
which what is she supposed to do do
something else what do you want me to do
[Music]
how to find us
not any
anymore are you ready for what you will
find here
what we will find
it's all for nothing
[Music]
they are waiting
to us
[Music]
thank you for this
all parts of here that are broken you
can be whole
the grief all the rage
[Music]
let me choose this place we've come so
far not far enough
say it you already tell them
you'll be here
now
we get lost forever
what will happen to them what will
happen to you
I will not let them down she's ready
go
[Music]
who are these around you Sarah
those you have saved
for those you led to death
[Music]